نعود ونذكر بالتطورات العاجله التي اشرنا
اليها قبل قليل وتابع هذه الصور المرتبطه
بها حيث قال الحرس الثوري الايراني في
بيان انه تم استهداف مواقع تجسسيه وارهاب
معاديه لايران في المنطقه واشار الحرس
الثوري في البيان ان الحرس الثوري قصف
مواقع لقاده وعناصر الجماعات الارهابيه في
سوريا بصواريخ بالستيه منتصف الليله ردا
على الهجمات الارها الاخيره في ايران حسب
البيان واكد البيان ايضا ان الحرس الثوري
سيعلن عن تفاصيل هذه العمليه والمواقع
الاخرى التي تم استهدافها لاحقا وفي هذا
السياق ذكرت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه
ايرنا ان الحرس الثوري الايراني قصف مواقع
تابعه لجماعات معاديه لطهران في اربيل
بالعراق
يا الله ماكو شي ماكو
شي الشباك
الشباك يا الله يا الله
يا
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
open
[موسيقى]
h